okay Dolly Parton is getting a massive
reward for giving back yes our country
Queen may be known for the biggest hair
and the highest heels and some of the
most successful songs in country music
but she is also one of the most
distinguished philanthropists and that
definitely needs celebrating yeah if
there's one name in music that brings
people together from all walks of life
it's Dolly Parton over her more than 60
years in the spotlight Dolly has put her
heart first making charitable efforts a
priority most recently the singer
donated one million dollars to the
Vanderbilt University's Medical Center
to help develop the moderna covid-19
vaccine in addition Dolly has founded a
number of Charities including the
Dollywood Foundation which focuses on
education and poverty relief yeah so in
honor of all of this Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos gifted Dolly with the Bezos award
for courage and civility so this was
over the weekend which included 100
million dollars going to the gym charity
of her choice take a look we have in
this very room the next recipient of the
courage and civility award the woman
you're about to meet embodies these
ideals so thoroughly she gives with her
heart what she's done for kids literacy
and so many other things is just
incredible it is my great honor to
welcome our 2022 courage and civility
award recipient up onto the stage Dolly
Parton
[Applause]
did you say a hundred million dollars
when people are in a position to help
you should help and I know that I've
always said I try to put my money where
my heart is and I think you do the same
thing I will do my best to uh to do good
things with this money thank you Jeff
[Applause]
it's your money where your heart is I
love that she's just such a legend I
mean she's always put other people first
she's always inspired people and I think
we need to see people like the Jeff
Bezos doing things like this we need
more of this in our world absolutely and
honestly I couldn't think of a better
person to receive this I I genuinely
think she's going to do really great
things with it I'm excited yeah I love
Dolly and I love how big her heart is
and I'm really excited to see her good
back